[Música]
isso mesmo eu sou filho de um imigrante
senegaleses que escolheu a espanha para
ligar a 30 anos meu pai emigrante que
mora hoje em espanha
então certamente vocês vão me perguntar
por que você escolheu aqui porque você
foi o espanhol
eu escolhi aqui não sou eu mas como
outros imigrantes
milhares de imigrantes que vivem hoje no
brasil
eu tenho um motivo suficiente para
escolher o brasil para viver um deles
andei pc sai do meu país para vir pra cá
center sozinho faz uma boa escolha
pensei 'o uma das escolhas brasil
historicamente é um país de acolhedor
claro na época ecolheu imigrantes
europeus e asiáticos tantos outros
hoje não foi diferente quando não
escolhendo meus conterrâneos senegaleses
haitiano deu tantos outros
esse é um dos motivos que escolhi brasil
outro motivo
eu cheguei em 2008 na época o brasil
estava bom e economicamente o mundo
estava em crise é um dos poucos países
que estava trilhando a crise é brasil
e se isso também um dos motivos a brasil
sempre admirei essa país como mensurar o
que ele tem de raças culturas e
universidades gerais as barreiras com
certeza são tantos
tantos tantos eu acho que cada um de
vocês pode imaginar
hoje você chegar na cena e gao sem falar
o idioma o cultura diferente
os costumes são diferentes religiões são
diferente então com certeza tudo isso
será um barreira incêndio que pode
trabalhar
eu me lembro quando eu cheguei no brasil
em 2008 segurança como é observado é uma
história bem engraçado mesmo tempo que
serve para refletir
cheguei você tem não só o que é
português nunca ouvi falar mas nunca
ouvi falar que quer portuguesas
então cheguei no hotel no dia seguinte
pediu para a moça que eu quero ir no
centro para visitar para tentar ver se
eu vou conhecer alguém na minha terra
aí pegou o táxi peguei um táxi foi no
centro quando cheguei no centro
aproveitei
eu tinha no bolso muitos dólares daí
troquei dólares e reais e deu multam
dinheiro um botão na minha cabeça era já
tão ricos
mal cheguei já tô milionário é pior com
muitos desses dinheiros era nota de um
real na época tinha que ela não tinha
verde e um reais e botei na bolsa era
discada era acabei gastando na centra no
mesmo dia que eu não podia gastar
cheguei no hotel como os a colina para
subir no meu quarto a moça da recepção
me chamou disse ele tem mandado como
dias pra pagar e disse
enquanto dois eu fizesse porque não não
falava português
aí ela tentou me explicar o que tem que
pagar
o mais alguns dias eu tirei interessante
pouco dinheiro que tinha
veio de day
ela diz não isso não é suficiente nisso
eu não consegui entender nada nada nada
e disse meu deus
então vou sair daqui procurar alguém que
me ajuda na interpretação além de não
tinha dinheiro suficiente me faz quanto
quem não entende nada do que ela estava
falando
ela saiu chama um taxista taxista disse
que ela ele fala francesa chegou como
que ela bonjo glória a deus
hoje o meu deus que eu vou dizer
eles tentaram explicar acessos que
dinheiro que eu tenho não é suficiente
para pagar mais dois dias no hotel
então o início de um baita batalha acaba
naquele dia dormir na rua
infelizmente isso por causa do idioma já
não entendemos agora me vem à mente
2 dias atrás então o conterrâneo que foi
no banco para abrir conta bancária
daí quando ele chegou a abrir o cofre
bancário faltou botar senha eu quanto
ele a moça pediu pra botar sênio no
entendimento dele era a assinatura que
ele tem que votar pediu caneta para a
moça
eu fui eu gosto disso mostra o que vai
fazer com isso ele não quer entender é
assim não mostra então para isso tentou
explicar com isso não é não estacionar a
tomar é séria
eles acabaram me procurar eu cheguei
expliquei isso meu deus eles nunca
palavra que trabalha o turno e
assinatura ele botou a série ele botou
no lugar na série a assinatura então
isso é muito milhares de outros exemplos
e engraçados que eu posso contar que
geralmente a idioma aqui que trabalha a
o presidente da associação de
senegaleses hoje em porto alegre
você sabe que essa galera se começa a
chegar a partir de 2008 mas a maior
parte deles em 2012 pra cá
então nessa meio tempo eu que já estava
aqui com mais alguns emigrantes
nós pensamos quando tem alguém melhor
para ajudar partilhar esses imigrantes
nisso nem só de nós criamos uma
associação que hoje conta com 700
integrantes em porto alegre
então a gente trabalha nos auxiliar de
moradia e educação e tentamos e ingerir
no mercado de trabalho e infelizmente
sabemos que hoje o mercado de trabalho
não é muito favorável mas do nosso jeito
a gente estava se virando é algumas que
não conseguiram adquirir no mercado de
trabalho pra sobreviver ansa ele entra
no mercado informal
então isso é um fato de só você
vivenciou mais nenhuma opção de ninguém
eu acho que ninguém note não queria e
nunca vai querer trabalhar informalmente
correndo atrás das fiscalizações riscos
de segurança é ser mal tratado
diariamente ninguém não gostaria então
se alguém o papel de fazer isso você
pode ter certeza na maioria das vezes
essa a opção é a parte de cultura casa
antes trabalho atua fortemente porque
não podemos deixar a cultura você sabe
tem certeza ao cultural africano e uma
das culturas mais rico que disse então
nisso a gente sempre organizamos eventos
culturais
vamos nas escolas também atuamos mostrar
que é que a nossa cultura porque no meu
entendimento no entendimento da
associação
muitos deles as pessoas reclamam a
presença dos imigrantes por falta de
conhecimento porque se não a conheça
alguém vai acabar julgando que ela
pessoas é realmente o mínimo
conhecimento então para atirar para
tirar essa barreira
a gente atua de vez em quando nas
escolas explicando as crianças quem
somos nós que aqui nós mesmos foi fazer
aqui é que nós temos na bagagem porque
nós não estamos aqui são e vão cada um
de nós
alguns têm qualificação profissional de
nível superior algumas de nós temos
cultura do chá no nosso futuro se temos
culturas muito risos muito ricas que a
gente pode oferecer professor brasileiro
a às vezes a gente organizamos alguns
álbuns entre nós para conversar
primeiramente porque caso estamos de
civil pra tirar nossa fronteira na nossa
frente
a agente o último vezes que a gente
organizamos foi mesmo passado um almoço
convidamos a pessoas de idade ele o
auxílio de psirico e mais algumas
pessoas mais necessitadas para almoçar
junto com nosso pra aproveitar e
explicando realmente nossa presença
nessa país a doações de sangue e de vez
em quando a gente organiza algumas
doações de sangue para doha
então tudo isso é nosso trabalho é
sábado passado recebemos também nos
chefe religioso que nosso também maioria
95% da população senegalês on muçulmanos
então o nosso muito forte e essa parte
de revisão é líder de nós sempre vem
aqui conversar à noite ou como nosso
mais a comunidade brasileira é legal
também é a culinária senegaleses é um
das culinárias mais ricas que existe na
terra
talvez desconhecido aqui mas se for o o
hoje na europa principalmente na frança
eles admiram muito admiro muito a comida
típica os senegaleses que é dominado
pela aol feijão arroz
feche a lua esporte favorito dos a
galera a luta tradição é para terminar
vou deixar pra você falar ah
caso alguma reflexão pode você pode
levar pra vida tudo a imigração
senegaleses pra cá não é pra sempre
é o tempo que vai passar logo daqui a
alguns anos não se fala mais em migração
será a galera inclusive a maioria das
senegalesas nós estão aqui para sempre
ele pretende um dia voltar ao mudar de
país e se tu tem oportunidade de pernas
um país algum jovem 95% do senegalês que
estão aqui não tem idade
mais de 25 anos de idade produtivo
muitos deles têm educação excepcional e
cultura porque não aproveitaram disso
passa num senegaleses na rua vendendo
para um minuto da abraço perguntou com
aberto como certa uma coisa que vai
fazer bem e vai vai fazer bem pra ele
pra sempre
é um pequeno acesso mais fácil a
diferença você porque eu quem estou
dizendo isso é só o mundo é nós a ser
humano criou barreira mas deus não criou
o barreiro não disse senegaleses
brasileiro em seu nome
então essa barreira pode ser derrubado
por que não
quem derrubou quem pode derrubar essa
barreira eu eu vou césar não podemos ter
preconceito e raça de origem o qual
coisa parecida porque é isso atrapalha o
mundo ao mundo hoje tá jeito que está
por causa disso se não tivemos barreira
com certeza seria melhor então vou
deixar essa dica pra vocês é nós estamos
aqui noe vão porque na época tínhamos
voz e som forçado de niro então hoje a
gente vive como livre à vontade raça a
brasil que é um país exemplo de acolher
nunca falamos
brasil um país que rejeita de imigrantes
hoje a gente você sabe que hoje estão
vivendo um boom no mundo em crise
humanitária e aqui graças a vocês nosso
fala isso
então mais uma vez obrigado pela
oportunidade
nosso português numa das melhores mas
tentamos falar de jeito que nós podemos
é isso aí obrigada pessoal
[Aplausos]